y podemos esperar que el papá presente
excusas por la responsabilidad de la
iglesia en esta masacre de niños y niñas
bueno en realidad la disculpa llega
tarde porque la iglesia católica tenía
el 75 por ciento de estas misiones o
escuelas residenciales como le llamaban
que eran
como campo de concentración
pero también el otro 25% lo tenían la
iglesia presbiteriana y anglicana y
iglesia unida y ellos ya pidieron
disculpas entonces
también hay molestia en los distintos
grupos
étnicos de canadá que se denominan with
primeras naciones y metis que
en haití también en el otro nombre que
viene existiendo de hace tiempo las
disculpas
juan pablo segundo estuvo en dos
oportunidades en canadá mil 984 y 2002 y
no pidió disculpas entonces si hay una
molestia con la iglesia católica pero
además la mayor parte de los indígenas
canadienses son católicos entonces es
una situación paradójica
en este caso
hay realmente acciones de parte del
vaticano que usted vea que van a
proteger a los niños después de los
miles de casos de abuso conocidos no
solamente en canadá sino en los últimos
años en todo el mundo
bueno hay un intento de francisco de
restaurar y
reconocer los abusos pedir disculpas
etcétera pero los sectores conservadores
de la jerarquía católica y de la propia
iglesia católica
se oponen a esto porque lo consideran la
pérdida de prestigio etcétera no ahora
también el papá ha convocado a un sínodo
colectivo con discusión durante tres
años etcétera como para una reingeniería
de la iglesia católica pero creo que los
sectores conservadores daban a boicotear
y nos esperan efectivamente cambios de
fondo además más allá de una disculpa
pocos procesos judiciales se ven en los
escándalos que involucran a la iglesia
católica y tampoco en imposiciones de
reparación porque sigue estando blindada
la institución se necesita mucho más que
una oración de perdón
los indígenas canadienses
piden
e
indemnizaciones a parte del
reconocimiento porque eso es como dar
una palmadita en la espalda no es cierto
sino que hay un sector concreto de los
pueblos indígenas que exigen algo más
contundente o de alguna manera
que le duela en el bolsillo a la iglesia
católica este es un punto de
controversia
y es lo que están planteando las
organizaciones y los pueblos indígenas
de canadá que están muy bien organizados